[Music]
can i tell you a secret
i'm working with an avenger
can i speak to your manager
[Music]
didn't realize you're supposed to bring
guns
it's almost christmas
i can't go home
until i fix this
should we be worried i'll be home for
christmas i promise
[Applause]
sorry shannon
we're the regular arrows
oh my god trick arrows
we're saving the holidays
marvel studios hawkeye first two
episodes streaming november 24th only on
disney plus
this is the first christmas we've had
together
in years
i love you guys
i'm making up for some lost time
authorities are wondering if the masked
vigilante who terrorized the city's
underworld is back
the past is caught up with me
should we be worried no no it's nothing
i'll be home for christmas i promise
[Music]
when i wore this suit
i made a whole lot enemies
you're a hawkeye who the hell are you
some people have actually called me
the world's greatest archer
are you one of those people it's the
most wonderful hey babe i should be back
in a day or two
hang on a second
things have gotten
[Music]
more complicated
[Music]
[Applause]
this too dangerous
definitely not this one you'll have to
say definitely like that
holy [ __ ]
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one
[Music]
this is some christmas
[Music]
you